salaam alaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends and dear non-muslims who
are
new to my channel hope you guys are
doing well um as you guys know yesterday
was a march regarding freedom of speech
um and it was hard by the far-right hate
preacher tommy robinson
and there's a video circulating uh of
one of
the brothers who was with us he was
defending himself
but the only footage i was taking out
was the edited version of him hitting
somebody yeah
so what i'm gonna do is guys i'm just
going to keep this very simple and short
we're going to watch a clip
yeah in that clip is what exactly
happened yesterday
from two different camera angles and
we're going to see even in slow motion
who started fighting in three separate
occasions
we've got cameras so there's no editing
going on you can clearly see from the
beginning
what started it and what caused it and
personally i want to say
it was an amazing day a lot of people
that we cannot personally reach out to
such as people who have a misconception
have a misunderstanding about islam
have been brainwashed by watching tommy
robinson and got this hate inside them
that one lady even came with bacon you
can even see on my channel i had a
discussion with this lady
and amazing people like justin i don't
know the another few other ladies
and it was really really constructing
really good so one thing that i want to
thank tony robinson besides the
hooliganism and the violence that he
always brings with himself is the fact
that he gathered these people in that
park
and we had the opportunity to convey the
message of islam and answer those
misconceptions
so let's watch this video forgive me for
speaking fast
watch this video it's about two minute
video you can clearly see for yourself
who started to fight and one thing i
want to make clear is i
am against any kind of violence period
except accept those who defend their
self every man and woman has a right to
defend their self please
let's go to the video and watch for
ourselves what really happened we've
been
peacefully discussing debating for weeks
and weeks and weeks and
years yes no issues whatsoever
the moment tommy robinson comes there
has to be
conflict the violence does not continue
with these militants and thugs
that have decided to come here with
weapons freedom to attack our freedom of
speech
ironically whenever tommy comes to any
location
he creates violence extremes intruderism
extremism he gets extremism he wants
he makes money out of this money out of
violence
[Music]
oh
all right
[Music]
[Music]
forget attacking muslims these guys look
what they did to a veteran who's a
regular at the park speaking on the
ladder
and you talk about freedom of speech all
the irony and hypocrisy
oh the irony and the hypocrisy man just
watch this video
watch what they do to him
[Applause]
[Music]
freedom of speech for the british people
yeah absolutely
not [ __ ] guys you clearly saw uh for
yourself
yes that freedom of speech is only for
them
not for the muslims or not for the
veteran so guys as you saw there
clearly three separate occasions right
is that
they try to hit that brother abdulhamid
on the head with the stick he grabs the
stick
takes it off them and goes and hits them
back that is what really happened
on the second one you can clearly see
that
they're in the front line both of them
yeah they're there there are no
fighting's happening
all of a sudden one of them throws
something at the brother and the other
one hits with the stick again
second time this is where it actually
began the first time and the brother
responds with a hook to the face
then the third video you can clearly see
the guy's putting his middle finger up
the muslim which i
think it's wrong he should not done that
yeah it's unnecessary but just to put
his middle finger up two times he tries
to swing that aim
and i think the brother returns it back
to him so we can clearly see
that is what's happened now we're not
going to allow this to divide us
i know tommy wants this division to
happen because of his personal problems
with muslims
yeah and i know his personal problems
are muslims it's very personal i'm not
going to go there
however we're not going to allow that
and we did not allow that to happen
here is a little clip of me speaking to
justin an amazing father
who had concerns for his daughter
dawson's future as well as myself
the videos on my channel besides that
here's a little clip of me and that lady
and how it ended check this out guys i
said tommy can you show me a verse
that claims that i should come and kill
this lady or you he did not give me one
single verse
but just just to wrap it up in a
nutshell it was nice talking to you
justin
and ladies thank you i'll respect you
yeah
yeah sure
so as you saw there i had many
discussions six seven of these
now point all that to a side tony
robertson his hooligans his violence
and also some of his really decent fans
his well who are concerns
let's talk about someone that's closer
to home
yeah now i'm going to be real with you
guys here i'm not going to say muslims
are perfect in the park no they're not
they've got a lot of things to work on
yeah
because allah says to us in the quran
speak the truth even if it's against
yourself
even against your family members you
have to be honest muslims got a lot of
working to do
and i agree their bad behavior and the
way they conduct itself i haven't
personally come across
outright violence however attitude the
way they speak just like anyone else
they have to fix up
however however i want you guys to watch
take a look at this picture this is a
picture of tommy robinson
with sarah big bro and another guy
yeah now when you see this picture it
looks all
you know like you know it's all happy
days hunky dory
yeah who are these people big bro
sarah is someone that i just outright
believe is just
a problematic person who's after fame
let's see who these people really are
the following three videos are videos
i've talked out for the past two three
years of the discussion we had with them
black supremists now you go watch it for
yourself
big bro is someone actually i'm actually
disappointed in here i had a discussion
with him about a year and a half ago
really nice discussion
we left in really good terms next thing
i know i'm blocked on twitter
and for some reason he's joined forces
with a hate preacher
like um tommy robinson who was caused
darren osborne to be radicalized and run
innocent muslims over
just the way andrew chowdhury preaches
hate and innocent
non-muslims die both of these hate
preachers tomorrow and childhood
one of the top counts of terrorism
experts have clearly said these people
are the same they feed off each other
and you join forces especially
especially
when you are a black supremacist
yourself and you call the white man a
devil
yeah and this reason why i'm doing this
video not a personal attack
but to show your hypocrisy both sarah
and yourself and gary
let's watch for ourselves and find out
what do these guys actually believe
about the likes of tommy robinson and
the general white british public
you know what i'm saying because they
are racist and they can't stay on camera
you are racist
in the world in terms of race 100 yes
okay do you reckon that black people
respective to other world races have an
agreement of advantage and superior
over over those races yes
[Music]
i'm not going to say nothing more guys i
think the matter is very clear and you
have seen for yourself
this racist behavior yeah
so we've got islamophobes from all kinds
joining forces
yeah we have allah we don't have that
concern
hope you guys have benefited shares with
your friends and family and expose
what really happened in the park and
thank you very much until next time
from the orthodox muslim goodbye